IT'S OFFICIALLY OSCAR SEASON AND
HERE TO GIVE PREDICTIONS FOR
HOLLYWOOD'S BIGGEST NIGHT IS
FILM CRITIC HARRY PINK.
>>.
>> MR. JOST, IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
BE BACK, MY SIR.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE SEEN
EVERY FILM UP FOR AN OSCAR THIS
YEAR.
AM I RIGHT?
>> BINGO.
AND EVERY FILM NOT NOMINATED
TOO.
IT'S BEEN ONE HECK OF A 48
HOURS.
>> YOU WATCHED EVERY SINGLE
MOVIE FROM THIS YEAR IN THE LAST
TWO DAYS?
>> YEAH?
>> AND HOW IS THAT EVEN
POSSIBLE?
>> THERE THANKS TO A LITTLE
MULTIVITAMIN I TAKE CALLED LSD.
LSD HELPS ME LSD ALL THESE
TERRIFIC.
FIRST UP, MY PICK FOR BEST FLICK
IS "POWER OF THE DOG."
WHO LET THE DOG OUT OF THE
CLOSET?
THAT'S THE QUESTION POSED BY
DIRECTOR JANE CAMPION IN THIS
HYSTERICAL GAY WESTERN.
BENEDICT CUMBERBATCH RIDES HIGH
AS THE TITULAR DOG THE BOUNTY
HUNTER, THAT IS, UNTIL BIZARRELY
STEPPING THROUGH THE SCREEN TO
MAKE FUN OF MY UNDIES IN THE
VOICE OF MY MIDDLE SCHOOL
BULLIES.
ASIDE FROM THAT, IT'S THE BEST
MOVIE I'VE EVER SEEN.
COLIN?
>> "POWER OF THE DOG" ISN'T
ABOUT DOG THE BOUNTY HUNTER.
AND YOU REALIZE LSD ISN'T A
VITAMIN, IT'S A HALLUCINOGEN.
>> YOU SAY TUMOTTO, I SAY --
[ MUMBLING ]
ALL RIGHT, NEXT UP, ANIMATION.
RHYTHMIC FUN FOR THE WHOLE
FAMILIA, "ENCANTO" FEELS WORSE
THAN BEING ON FIRE.
HAND-DRAWN BY LEGENDARY AUTEUR
THE ZODIAC KILLER, THIS ALL GRAY
THROBBING STRESS DREAM DOES DRAG
IN SPOTS.
BUT LOCAL GANGSTER RAPPER
LIN-MANUEL SAMANTHA SAVES THE
DAY ONCE AGAIN WITH HIS CATCHY
HIT "12 HOURS OF SCREAMING."
CATCHY TUNE.
THIS FILM WARMED MY HEART, BROKE
MY BRAIN, DILATED MY PUPILS TO
THE SIZE OF PIE PLATES, THEN
STOLE MY KIDNEY AND SOLD IT FOR
DOGECOIN.
I GIVE "ENCANTO" 10 TINY
TERRIFIED TERRYS.
MR. PRESIDENT?
>> OH, MAN.
I'M REALLY STARTING TO WORRY
ABOUT YOU, TERRY.
>> AND I'M STARTING TO WORRY
THERE IS NO TERRY.
>> OKAY.
>>> NEXT UP, MY PICK FOR BEST
ORIGINAL SCREENPLAY, KENNETH
BRANAGH'S
"BELFAST."
JOHNNY KNOXVILLE AND HIS MERRY
BAND OF IDIOTS FLOP AROUND TOWN
AND TORTURE EACH OTHER'S BALLS
IN THIS TROUBLED-ERA TEAR
JERKER.
BUT IT'S DAME JUDI DENCH WHO
LITERALLY SOARS AS WEE-MAN SHOT
OUT OF A CANNON INTO MY OPEN
MOUTH, YUMMERS!
I COULDN'T START LAUGHING OR
CRYING OR DOING THE NAY-NAY
UNTIL I WAS FORCIBLY REMOVED BY
REGAL CINEMA'S STRONGEST TEAM.
I GIVE "JACKASS BELFAST" 40
TWERKING TICKLISH TERRYS.
TERRY?
>> YOU ARE TERRY.
>> AND YOU'RE A WONDERFUL
FRIEND.
>> TERRY FINK, EVERYONE.
>> I'M GOING TO DO IT, YEAH.
SOME DAY.